foreign
[Music]
have you ever been in need of a tool
that you didn't have
imagine that you have this screw that
you need to unscrew but you don't have
the right screwdriver to do that
so what do you do
go to the nearest hardware store you
look at the various screwdrivers they
have bigger smaller different screw
heads you pick the one that will match
your screw you bring it home you unscrew
you're good
sometime passes
you want to find a table that will match
the space between our sofa and the wall
but you don't have a measuring tape and
you need one so what do you do
you go to the nearest hardware store
look at the various measuring tapes they
have
longer shorter thinner wider start
wondering why that even matters but you
need to make a decision so we pick one
bring it home measure you're good
sometime passes
you need to hammer a nail
so what do you do
you start wondering wouldn't this make
sense to buy a complete toolbox instead
of assembling one two by two
my name is Camille I'm a full stack
engineer at absilon
we specialize in building shiny
applications
let me tell you of a typical situation
that we faced many times over in our
work
so a client comes to us and asks what we
could build an application for them
using wonderful capabilities of shining
we create something within a couple of
hours that is interactive and impresses
the client
contract signed the project starts
a couple of weeks pass the code base
grows 20 times
and realize that
we are spending a lot of time discussing
the code style where the opening bracket
should be
we figure that we need some tool that
will automatically check this for us we
need a linter
so what do we do
we find lint R we configure it properly
we add it to the project we start
linking our code we're good
sometime passes
we realize that we touch one place in
the application and something else
breaks
so we figure that we should start
writing tests we need unit tests what do
we do
we find test that we configure it we add
it to the project we start writing unit
tests we're good
some time passes
and you'll get a point
needs keep arising and we need to keep
addressing them we start wondering
wouldn't it make sense to start with a
complete development toolbox instead of
assembling one tool by Tool
this goes deeper though in case of
development tools
introducing them later on in the project
is typically more costly for example if
you want to add winter when you already
have hundreds of linter Errors you'll
first have to fix them all and that's
not only a lot of work but you need to
synchronize it with your team
but we should take even a wider
perspective though it's not just one
project it's multiple teams dealing with
multiple projects at the same time and
similar needs arise in each of those
projects and each team keeps configuring
the same tools
wouldn't it be wonderful to have just
one universal toolbox
all this effort could be directed into
really polishing it instead of
Reinventing the wheel all the time
moreover in a non-organization
when you have just one universal toolbox
people get proficient using it so when
you start a new project or move to a
different one everybody's up to speed
right from the beginning this can really
bring the productivity to a whole new
level
so you can see what kind of problem we
have here
and this is where my personal Story
begins
right here in the middle so I joined
Epsilon two years ago in July
it was a hot month my brother was coming
it was the last month of our only office
being open pandemic was raging lots of
things were happening
so my first project was called project
patterns
what was that
well technically speaking it was a git
repository with Snippets of code on
branches and the related python tool
that could be used to combine them into
project structure for new and existing
projects
sounds complicated it was and it was my
task to improve it
so first of all I try to understand the
proposal for this and I started
researching what we tried to do about
this in the past
and it turned out that we did a lot
like years before already we had
discussion groups and we had the
repository of code Snippets that could
be reused to some extent
directly before project patterns we had
something called we had a setup
involving our studio in Docker and the
related bash tool that could be used to
automate some of the things
so I realized that already many people
before me tried to solve these problems
that we had and I had the week to
improve that you can guess that I didn't
manage to fix everything within that
week but for the following two years we
kept improving what we had
for example we went through a phase of
simplification where instead of having
all these complex set of tools we
created just a simple shiny template a
git repository that could be cloned and
used as a basis for your project
we've also researched other tools for
example we took a look at Golem we tried
to learn how it differs from our
approach we tried to learn from it we've
considered whether we could just use it
so for two years we kept addressing
needs as they were arising resolving
issues as they were surfacing
finally in year 2022 we started feeling
that we have something that we want to
share within the world and thus
Rhino was born
no not this rhino rhino the free and
open source r package which we announced
in May this year during Epsilon shiny
conference
so it's in our package means it has
functions for example this rhino init
function
it creates a new Rhino project for you
so what do you get inside
perhaps the most obvious part is the
full project structure of files and
directories so we have places for
configuration source files dependencies
tests everything is covered from the
beginning so let's take a deeper look at
some of those
any project will need other R packages
to do its job and it's very important to
be explicit about what these other
packages are and what versions you need
if you are not explicit about that you
might find that when you try to launch a
project after a couple of months it
doesn't work why
who knows maybe some Patrick package got
updated and it broke if you have an
explicitly list of dependencies the
chances that it will just work Are Much
Higher and we have our end package to
deal with this
for a similar issue but related to the r
sources themselves we have the box
package this one allows you to use
Python style Imports at the top of each
file so that for each file it is
immediately obvious what packages
functions and other files it needs
so moving on to the quality of our code
we have three packages which deal with
that for writing tests we have test that
package then we have linked R which can
be used to automatically test the style
of your codes and also detect some
errors that you might have
and we have the styler package which is
able to fix many of those problems
automatically
all these tools can be run using Rhino
functions out of the box you don't need
to configure anything you just do for
example Rhino Lind R and you get your
code linted
so in Enterprise settings typically you
will have some needs that will be quite
common for example one of them is
logging it is very important to Output
good log messages from your application
if it breaks for example in production
this kind of log messages can really
help you to find what the issue is and
we have the logger package which deals
with that
then
you typically will have more than one
environment you will have the local one
when you develop the application then
you will have staging where you will be
testing it before pushing it to
production and to manage the differences
between these different environments we
have the config package
now in any big project we realized that
sooner or later we need JavaScript we
need to customize the application Beyond
what's provided by our packages and we
figured why not use the state-of-the-art
tag for that
so for JavaScript we will run your code
through bubble and webpack this tool
ensure that you can use the latest
features without worrying about browser
support
we have aslint that you can use to check
the quality of your JavaScript code and
also fix many of the errors
automatically while these things need
node.js to be installed on your machine
when using it from Rhino you will just
call the package functions build.js
link.js
now similarly we typically need to add
some custom styling and we chose SAS to
do that it's an extension for the CSS
language which allows you to structure
your code in a more maintainable and
better way and again here to compile
your SAS into something understandable
by the browser we use the
state-of-the-art latest implementation
of SAS we also have style linked which
is able to link your style files
automatically
now what else do you need in a big
project well certainly more testing and
as we already are using node.js we are
using also Cypress for end-to-end
testing of your application this
framework allows you to launch your
whole application interact with it like
Press buttons type text and then verify
if it behaved as expected for example
that some text appeared or window got
opened
so again this can be used simply by
running a function of the package called
test end-to-end
and finally
as a cherry on top automation all these
tools are useless if you are not
actually running them and if it's not
happening automatically sooner or later
you'll probably forget about it so if
you use GitHub
Rhino comes with a working out of the
box setup for GitHub actions this will
run all the linters unit tests and
student tests for you automatically once
you initialize your project
all right so to summarize what is Rhino
well certainly you can think of it as
this complete development toolbox with
all those things that I have just listed
and mentioned but it's more than that
we call it a framework
and if you know other Frameworks go for
python or Ruby on Rails we took a
slightly different angle here while you
do get the project structure packages to
use and like basic structure for your
application
we also have all these tools around it
for ensuring the quality of your code
so we can think of rhino as a framework
but for the whole development process
then Rhino is certainly the absolute way
to do things
it is an opinionated framework based on
years of experience that we have in
building shiny applications
it is not the only way to to do things
but it is the way that we believe in and
that we recommend
and finally
Rhino is great for Enterprise while you
can certainly use it in your next proof
of concept project that you will show to
nobody
its benefits really start to shine in
organizations when you have this one
universal toolbox which everybody can
use it really can bring your
productivity to a new level
so
I hope this got you a bit interested in
Rhino perhaps maybe even somewhat
excited
so if if that's the case all you need to
do is to go to our website it contains
an extensive documentation for the
package as we believe it is an essential
part of a framework like this
so thank you for listening and I
encourage you to use right now in your
next project
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]